le retour d'un métier ancien que le
normand claude monet aurait apprécié
celui de bouilleur ambulant exemple chez
nous en val de loire où depuis quelques
mois thibault pelletier déplace son
alambic de village en village pour
transformer les fruits en eau de vie de
poire de prune ou de cerises elle trouve
à chaque fois leur public voyait ce
reportage près de château renault de
samuel colin 100 litres de prunes et une
marmite prêt à bouillir première étape
de la distillation
faire chauffer ce macérat de sucre et de
fruits de la saison passée pour extraire
les vapeurs d'alcool donc cette vapeur
là va venir dans la colonne qu'on
appelle de rectification donc qu on
refroidit plus ou moins et vapeurs
d'alcool qui sont plus légères vous
montez et ensuite vont descendre dans un
serpentin hélas vont se transformer en
eau-de-vie cet alambic de quelques
années de plus que thibaut pelletier et
son nouvel outil de travail
à 24 ans le jeune homme reprend une
activité de bouilleur ambulant entre
cinq communes et trois départements
il reste à chaque fois une dizaine de
jours sur place à partir de la mi
décembre jusqu'à mimer un travail
saisonnier qu'il découvre dès l'enfance
c'est un métier que je connais depuis
longtemps quand même on va dire que je
suis tombé dans la marmite petit car mon
père
mais exerce le métier depuis 1987 donc
j'ai toujours voulu perdurer la
tradition que c'est un très vieux métier
un métier de plus en plus rare à la
réglementation contraignante
le jour de la distillation il faut
attendre 18 heures pour repartir avec
l'alcool produit un alcool taxes et 90
euros pour 20 litres l'eau-de-vie sort à
65 degrés le bouilleur douala baptisé il
la coupe avec de l'eau pour atteindre 50
degrés maximum
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut apporter
sa récolte
mais bon sang laissant les deux de
chaque sa vie de prune sa mine de croire
on avait à syndicats beaumont la ronce
mais c'est fini puis après je suis allé
à drache et c'est fini aussi donc je
suis rendu ici parce que des bouilleurs
de cru en voie de disparition je pense
le jeune bouilleur attend environ 25
personnes cette semaine le gel du
printemps a cependant détruit une grande
partie des bourgeons dans les vergers
l'hiver prochain son activité devrait
donc s'en ressentir